ständig nehmen wir einfluss auf die
entscheidungen von anderen menschen und
genau so werden wir auch beeinflusst
meistens unbewusst und mehr als uns lieb
ist die psychologen und
neurowissenschaftler rind alischer rott
forscht für solche mechanismen ihr neues
buch ist ein passender bericht darüber
wie manipulierbar wir sehen wollen sie
in den nächsten diskussion mit diesen
argumenten punkten nun diese freunde von
ihrer meinung überzeugen
dazu müssen sie wissen wie ihr gehirn
funktioniert wenn wir wissen wie unser
verstand arbeitet wenn wir wissen wie
überzeugungen entstehen dann haben wir
das werkzeug unsere botschaft einfacher
durchzubringen
doch selbst die neurowissenschaftlichen
ließ sich beeinflussen als sie eine
fernsehdebatte mitverfolgte darin ging
es um das für und wider von impfungen
der arzt und impfbefürworter ben carson
argumentierte mit fakten und zahlen
sein widersacher donald trump führte
emotionen wunderschöne kleine jahn in
einem gespräch nahm eine spritze und so
aussieht als wäre sie für ein pferd
gemacht neulich bekam ein kinder die
solche impfung und später hat es hohes
fieber war der krank und jetzt dieses
auto meine reaktion war allein das ist
schrecklich
obwohl ich die statistiken kannte diese
emotionale beschreibung hatte eine große
wirkung auf mich weil ich selber ein
kleines baby neben ihm hatte ich war
besorgt dass mein baby auch sehr krank
werden könnte
ein beispiel dafür dass zahlen und
fakten nicht überzeugen
es sind gefühle und geschichten die
haltungen nr
marie charlott möchte keine kleinen
trump sichten
dennoch sie zeigten ihrem buch die
meinung der anderen beispiele von
beeinflussung positiver beeinflussen
der amerikaner jerry meyer und die
französischen firma sind glücklich
verheiratet und erwarten achten
sie sind sich nur in einem thema uneins
in welchem land ihre kinder aufwachsen
sollen sie plädiert für frankreich weil
dort die löhne höher sei er für amerika
dessen bildungssystem
sie überbieten sich mit zahlen und
fakten ergebnis gegen hinein und von
jemandem zu argumentieren sperrten
überzeugung staaten zu schwächen
die lösung firma gibt ihr mann nicht das
bildungssystem in den usa verbrechen und
überzeugte ihn dann mit einem
emotionalen perfekt sie würden alle
glücklicher sein in frankreich weil sie
näher bei den großeltern wenn ich von
etwas überzeugen
mutig wissen was du glaubst denn du
wirst doch ich sage immer mit einer
überzeugung vergleichen
anstatt durch thema sagt ich will nach
frankreich ziehen weil es besser ist
sagt sie weil es näher an meiner familie
ist das widerspricht wiederum als
prioritäten noch seinen wünschen die
überzeugungen anderer mit einzubeziehen
ist also die voraussetzungen ihre
entscheidungen zu beeinflussen
ein weiteres verblüffendes beispiel aus
dem buch meine frau möchte ihrem
unsportlichen man dazu bringen häufiger
ins fitnessstudio zu bieten doch ihre
warnungen vor übergewicht und drohendem
herzinfarkt flucht nicht geändert
daraufhin ihre strategie nach einem
seiner seltenen fitness besucher lobte
seine muskeln
gutes aussehen es wirkt unmittelbare
belohnung funktioniert besser als
potenzielle bedrohung heißt das dass für
eine positive zukunft versprechen
effizienter verarbeitet
wenn man jemandem eine bedrohung in der
zukunft voraussagt denkt die person
passiert ist doch nicht so gut weil man
hingegen positive perspektiven aufzeigt
hören die leute eher zu ein beispiel
anstatt einem jugendlichen zu sagen wenn
du raus bekommst du krebs sollte man ihn
sagen wenn du nicht raus schaffst du es
er entfachte bei der man trainiert nun
wie verrückt um sich weiteres lob seiner
frau zu sichern
hoffnung machen bringt also
längerfristig meeres angst fühlen
trotz buch die meinung der anderen zeigt
auf faszinierende weise wie wir
entscheidungen treffen und die unserer
mitmenschen beeinflussen können positiv
wie negativ
fünf sterne erhöht dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit weiterer positiver
bewertungen um 25 prozent das ist die
mensch eine einzige person beeinflusst
also die ratings unglaublich viele und
anzunehmen dass etwas wahr ist nur weil
viele behaupten
das ist gefährlich die mechanismen der
manipulation zu durchschauen was leistet
dieses wer eine entscheidung fällt und
sich nach der lektüre öfter fragen warum
er es tut
wenn sie jetzt entschieden haben von
dieser zahl heraus kann ich lernen dann
empfehlen